reino unido es el más reciente país en
confirmar un caso la nueva variante del
corona virus bautizada omicron está en
circulación la organización mundial de
la salud la declaró el viernes variante
de preocupación lo que ha llevado a cada
vez más países a suspender los vuelos
desde y hacía hasta 8 países del sur de
áfrica donde la nueva variante fue
detectada por primera vez la unión
europea fue la primera en aplicar estas
restricciones
en commerce + la comisión europea ha
propuesto hoy a los estados miembros que
activen la interrupción de los viajes
desde los países del sur de áfrica y
otros países afectados para limitar la
propagación de la nueva variante
desde entonces la lista de países con
restricciones similares crece
eeuu
he decidido que vamos a ser cuidadosos
que vamos a asegurarnos de que no haya
viajes hacia y desde sudáfrica y otros
seis países de esa región
'israel olmedino está áfrica con todos
los países africanos con la excepción de
los países del norte de áfrica se
definen a partir de este momento como
países rojos australia effective mayday
e igual cualquier persona que no sea
ciudadano de australia o sus
dependientes y que haya estado en países
africanos donde se ha detectado y
propagado a la variante omicron en los
últimos 14 días no podrá entrar en
australia en américa latina países como
guatemala argentina y brasil tomaron
medidas similares
brasil cerrará sus fronteras aéreas a 6
países africanos por la nueva variante
del coronavirus sin embargo las
recomendaciones de la ms no iban en esta
dirección
roberto recomendó la o ms recomienda que
los países continúen aplicando un
enfoque basado en la ciencia y en la
evaluación de los riesgos a la hora de
aplicar las medidas relativas a los
viajes así que en esta fase de 9 no se
recomienda la aplicación de medidas de
viajes y el mundo intenta contener la
propagación de la variante que tiene
unas 30 mutaciones y que podría ser más
transmisible que las previas aún se
desconoce cuál será el verdadero impacto
de omikron